good morning Hank it's Friday I have not
had an a number one week in fact I've
had like a P number six weeks certainly
not a Z number ten that's as bad as it
can get but definitely in the bottom
half so Hank Wednesday morning I woke to
the news that more than a thousand
copies of my new book The Fault in Our
Stars have been prematurely shipped by a
bookseller to people who pre-ordered it
that was pretty bad because the book
isn't supposed to come out for three
more weeks and for the last year penguin
and I have both worked extremely hard to
make sure that everyone can read the
book at the same time in fact before
today every single person who read The
Fault in Our Stars including you and me
had to sign very intimidating-looking
non-disclosure agreements and payment
spent a lot of money on an embargo and
we didn't send the book to the people
we'd usually send it to like book
critics and movie people and foreign
publishers all of this was because I
really do not want the books foil for
the very nice people who want to read it
sorry I lost my temper a little bit
there take it down and there okay this
is particularly true for the very nice
people who are passionate enough about
The Fault in Our Stars to preorder it
but really I don't want the book spoiled
for anyone let me make my first book
Looking for Alaska came out almost seven
years ago so you would think that it's
okay to post spoilers but it's not
because this week thousands of people
bought Looking for Alaska who don't know
what it's about and who don't want it
spoiled for that but of course think
this is one of the great struggles of
the Internet when we read or hear or
watch something that we like we want to
talk to people about it and that the
internet is great at that but the
Internet is terrible at keeping secrets
I mean Hank if the internet was one of
my high school friends it would be me
but seriously Hank did you hear about
Shawn and Kim because something
definitely happened I'm not gonna get
into details second base so listening I
understand that not everyone who comes
to the Fault in Our Stars is going to
come to it without spoilers and I also
understand that this shipping error was
an error it was a mistake and it was an
honest mistake there was no
maliciousness involved today when I
heard about this I immediately thought
of george RR martin who when his most
recent embargoed book was leaked said if
we find out who is responsible for this
we will mount his head on a spike that
seemed a little crazy to me when i first
read it but Wednesday morning I found
myself somewhat more sympathetic to
George RR Martin's position and then I
called you Hank because that's what I do
when I'm mad and you reminded me of
something which is that my readers don't
just care about my books they care about
each other and then Hank has word leaked
out that this had happened I saw more
and more nerdfighters on Twitter and
Tumblr and Facebook saying that they
were going to
at the book early but they weren't going
to read it until January 10th or saying
they were going to read it but pledging
not to ruin the reading experience for
the vast majority of people who will not
receive their books until at least
January 10th Hank it's been a P number
six week but I was reminded again never
to underestimate nerdfighteria which is
always an a-number-one community those
of you who have read Looking for Alaska
may know that there are a lot of reasons
why I want this book to come out On
January 10th The Fault in Our Stars has
been with me in some form for more than
a decade and I am so excited to be less
than three weeks away from sharing it
but I really want everyone to have the
same reading opportunity so thanks in
advance for not posting spoilers I also
have to say Hank this thing could have
spiraled way out of control and I have
to thank Amazon and every independent
bookstore in the world for not shipping
their pre-orders in response to this
leak that was really really cool of them
and I appreciate it because it allows us
to keep the January 10 publication date
the fall nurse SARS is still available
for pre-order and in the meantime I did
write some other books that you can read
nerdfighters thank you again for caring
not just about Hanks music and my books
and the videos we make but about each
other this is a big hug for you thank
you for being awesome I am so so lucky
please don't post spoilers Hank I will
see you in real life in like two and a
half weeks oh my gosh but in the
meantime I will see you on the Internet
on Monday
Oh